Kaffee ist quasi eine allzweckwaffe, um technische träume aller art wahr werden
Zu lassen faltbare handys der antrieb von raumschiffen durch sonnenenergie oder sogar eine revolution der
batterietechnologie das alles ist möglich
und grafiken kann wirklich viel es ist das wohl dünnste material der welt
und dabei härter als diamant welche weiteren absolut krassen eigenschaften hat kaffee außerdem noch wann setzt sich endlich als
Wundermaterial durch oder ist das alles nur, ein riesengroßer hype das alles und viel mehr jetzt den klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Tausend dank für diesen wirklich mega spannenden themen vorschlagen das ist wirklich absolut bahnbrechend über whatsapp. Wie er da dabei sein könnte, und noch
ein kleines geschenk abstaubt das erfahrt am ende des videos
300 mal fester als stahl
Härter als diamant
Flexibler und leitfähiger als kupfer. Und zudem das wohl dünnste material der welt grafen vor zehn. Jahren hat
ein forschungsteam für die herstellung einer
Anatomischen lager grafen den. Nobelpreis bekommen und seitdem überschlagen. Sich die schlagzeilen
Zu diesem thema konkret besteht graffin aus einer einzigen transparenten schicht aus kohlenstoffatomen und diese zweidimensionalität
Tatsächlich ist ein kleines wunder denn eigentlich ist alles mit dem wir zu tun haben
Dreidimensional die kohlenstoff atome in graphen sind ähnlich angeordnet wie bienenwaben. Und genau das macht seinen vielen
Superlativ eigenschaften aus und so haben wir hier in clips, um jahr schon
Erst vor kurzem über den erfolg eines forschungsteams aus südkorea berichtet die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler hatten grafen
Erstmalig in großen mengen. Und zudem noch, zu einem vernünftigen preis hergestellt
Ihr langfristiges ziel ist es ein graf enac. Herzustellen das innerhalb von nur
Zwölf minuten voll geladen ist bei der produktion erinnern die vielen kleinen grafen bälle
ein wenig an popcorn die grafen welle sollen in
Lithium-ionen-akkus sowohl an der kathode als auch an der anode verwendet werden und deren ladegeschwindigkeit
Enorm, erhöhen, um das sind wir den teil zu verstehen braucht man, ein bisschen
Chemie die kohlenstoffatome im café sitzen jeweils auf den ecken von
Regelmäßig angeordneten sechsecken die atome wechselwirken ihre elektrischen felder überlagern sich das verhalten der elektronen
führt dazu dass strom
1,5 mal besser geleitet wird als es bei kupfer der fall ist denn die kohlenstoff atome in graphen sorgen
dafür dass sich die ladungsträger
Quasi, masse los fühlen doch erst in einigen. Jahren können wir
Wohl, darauf hoffen dass solche akkus indes in industriellem stil hergestellt werden. Können doch der erfolg des forschungsteams der kann auch. Anderen
Industriezweigen von nutzen sein sich eben ebenfalls mit akku technologien auseinandersetzen oder dazu damit, zu tun haben zum beispiel
Könnten graffin bälle bei der konstruktion von elektroautos helfen da sie extrem
temperatur stabil sind samsung wetterte zu recht ein großes geschäft das unternehmen hat bereits patente in südkorea und den usa
Für seine herstellung der kaffee in belle angemeldet. Und es gibt eine weitere superlative die mit graphen
konstruiert werden könnte
Kamerasensoren aus graphen könnte es möglich machen auch bei der nacht oder anderen schlechten lichtverhältnissen tolle bilder zu machen
Denn, sie sehen, sie werden. Wohl
1000 mal
Lichtempfindlicher als die sensoren die derzeit, eingesetzt werden graffin, eignet sich auch bestens für den
einsatz in der umwelt beispielsweise
Um boden wasser oder luft aufzubereiten denn es kann weiter verarbeitet werden
Zu stark absorbierende material mit dem sich zum, beispiel ölunfälle bekämpfen ließen
Ein bereits entwickelte sie aus kaffee macht aus meerwasser
Sauberes trinkwasser auch im medizinischen, bereich könnte graphen, eingesetzt werden
Ein, forschungsteam aus schottland will eine künstliche haut aus solarzellen entwickeln die
einen roboter eine roboterhand mit strom
Versorgt das café könnte die solarzellen noch leitfähiger, und lichtdurchlässiger machen aber auch im bereich kleidung wird kaffee bereits
Eingesetzt in china kann, beispielsweise hilft es wärme von warmen körperregionen
Zu kälteren zu transportieren zudem reduziert ist die reibung mit luft und wasser so dass graphen kleidung also dazu
Beitragen könnte sportler agiler, und leistungsfähiger. Zu machen doch es gibt, einen wermutstropfen
So richtig hat sich graphen bis jetzt nicht durchgesetzt. Und das trotz seiner
unvergleichlichen eigenschaften forschungsteams
Weltweit sind sich einig dass das potenzial riesig ist autos und flugzeuge könnten durch graf in ein viel geringeres gewicht haben
Und so deutlich weniger treibstoff verbrauchen die smartphone produktion könnte deutlich preiswerter werden
Und die akkutechnologie wie gesagt
Revolutioniert werden dort derzeit gibt es einfach noch zu viele technische probleme
Sowohl an der produktion größerer mengen grafen als auch am preis. Dafür scheitert es bislang es gibt nicht wirklich
entsprechende anlagen zur herstellung
Und weil die nachfrage nicht groß genug ist nicht investiert. Ein teufelskreis, denn
Dadurch wird das material natürlich nicht günstiger experten see und experten sehen uns an einem punkt. Wo die
Grundlagenforschung zur innovation übergehen und so kooperation mit der industrie notwendig sind und die patente von samsung
die lassen ja schon oft schon seit
2013 läuft eine große graffin initiative der europäischen union
Durch die die erforschung von graphen finanziell gefördert wird in fünf bis zehn
Jahren, sollte es dann auch bei uns, im alltag angekommen sein
So die prognose wir können also sehr sehr sehr gespannt sein und es dürfte wohl, einen extremen
Technologischen schub bedeuten hierbei klicks und dann natürlich, alle neuigkeiten und wenn er kein video dazu
Und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst
Ihr kein video denn die abo box auf youtube die ist ja ein bisschen
Lückenhaft über whatsapp erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert. Und zur begrüßung habe ich noch
Ein kleines geschenk für euch einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks, um, social and media abonnieren da erfahrt
Ihr das neueste aus der social media welt aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken kernfusion haben wir bald den ersten funktionierenden reaktor bis. Dann
bleib dran